まあ余計な話で まあそれはまあ一応 2番目の説明に入るところで
あの 1番目の説明も理解していない間でね
2番目の説明 それからまた 3番目の説明ありますけどね
まあそれはやめます で
佐藤さん言った通りに
この体を通して目を通して見ているならば
まあ距離を飛ばすことはできない
そこで同じ見ることなんですけど
目を通さない で 目を通しても脳細胞を通しても見るのは心なんですよ
それで目も脳細胞も通すなよと
通しちゃうと時間がかかります
それで体から心を自由にするんですね
自由にしたら距離を飛ばして見ることはできます
しかし それに最初の段階で体に対する執着を離れなくちゃいけないんですよ
能力育てたければ このカマーチャンダという欲
何でしたっけ あれは まあ五蓋の 1番目ありましてね
まあ心を覆っている蓋がありますからね
1番目はカマーチャンダ
まあ欲ですね 欲っていうのは体に対する執着
欲ですね それが離せないと
捨てないと で この距離を飛ばすっていうことはありえないんです
そこでどうやって体にある執着を離れるかという
離すかというと体迷惑
なぜかというと あらゆる情報を伝えてくれる
情報を伝えれば伝えるほど心が混乱する
集中力がなくなる 集中力がなくなると心は痛む
苦しみが増える ですから
情報を伝わってくるこのチャネルを切りましょうということで切らなくちゃいけない
それで心には距離飛べる能力あるんですけど
飛ばせません 知ることはまあ結構大変ややこしいんです
しかし その能力ある人が見る場合は
この望遠鏡で見るよう
プロが望遠鏡を使っているような感じですから
かなり丁寧に丁重に扱って合わせて必要なものだけ見てスイッチオフにする
例えば大型の望遠鏡なんかは微妙な動きで動かしてますけど
全部コンピューターで制御しているでしょうね
微妙な数字をコンピューターに入れて入れたら
もうあの巨大な機械がゆっくり動いて必要なところに合わせてくれる
で 私たちはもう子供たち連れて行って
あんなバカでかい天体望遠鏡あるんだから
見たい放題星見てやるぞと言ったっても
何も見えませんよ  そんなふうな
結構ややこしいんです
それでこのドゥーランダワンっていうのはそういうことで
この距離を飛ばせるというね
例えばすぐにエーカチャラン
一人で旅するということはなんとなくわかるような気がするでしょうにね
で 母親のことを思い出すためには別に携帯はいりませんし
写真もいりませんし 写真を見て母親を思い出すとか
それはいりません ただ心だけで思い出すことはできます
しかし それもまたかえって一般人のやり方っていうのはちょろいもんなんだ
大したことないんです
本当に心と体を自由にしちゃうと
エーカチャランっていうのは別な働きになるんです
我々はどう見たっても
何か物質を媒介して思い出してるんです
だから 例えばすぐ母親の思い出して似顔絵を描いてくださいって言ったら
うーんというふうに考える
まず 時間かかるんですよ
あれは物質を媒介させてるんです
させて 何かの顔を思い出すんです
本当のところで思い出せないですよ
母親の顔 思い出せないと思います
今の子の顔を見ると 自分の母親なんですけど
私はあえて母親の例出したのは出したのはそういうわけなんです
面白いことを じゃあ思い出してみてください
思い出せるかと 思い出せないんです
思い出せる？出した 簡単に思い出せる人方がいるだろうから
うん だからこの簡単に思い出せない
思い出そうとすると 私は
私は協力してあげることできますよ
じゃあこういう風にやったらどうでしょうかと
その時は顔を思い出しますけどね
協力はどういう風にするかというと
やっぱり物質を倍加させるんです
もともと母親の顔が思い出せないからくりになってるんです
それを知らないみんな
すごく母親のことを大事に思ってるんだぞというふうに自己満足で自画自賛してるんです
大事にしてないんです
自分のことだけ可愛くて
母に対して親切な態度を取った覚えがないんです
だから思い出せないんです
思い出せる方法というのは
たった一回だけでも母に対して自分もちょっと心配してあげたことがあるならば
その場面は私は思い出してあげるんです
そのきっかけで母の顔が思い出すんです
まあほとんどまあ古い人間だから
若い人はわかりませんだけど
母のおっぱい吸ったでしょ？あのおっぱいの感触を覚えていますかね
なんでそんなにも失礼な人間ですかね
私なら匂いも覚えていますけど
匂いも感触も味は覚えていない
正直に だからこの 我々は何か思い出そうとしちゃうと
何かもう物質的な場面があって
それ言うと 例えばあの小学生
小学校に連れて行った時
母親どんな一緒に行ったのか
どんなことでしょうかと言うと思い出すんです
その場面 その場面に出た母親の顔が思い出すんであって
これが本当に母親の顔ですかね
そんなもんで ですから
この心が一人で歩くんだぞと言っても
我々の場合はもうなんか純粋じゃないんですね
一人歩きの場合でも物質を使おうとする
でもあの いくらか肉体に対する執着をいくらかではなくて
置いておけば 心は一人で歩いてくれます
そういうことで そのそういう心を調教すると束縛から離れるんだということで
これはもうどういう意味でしょうかね
これは前も説明したことと同じで
心は知る機能 心には何でも知ることはできる
では瞑想して何でも知ってやるぞと言ったら成り立たない
知ること自体が苦しみだから
執着だからシロシロしているでしょうし
執着によって苦しむでしょうし
だからあの逆法則を使うんです
データを遮断するという
だからデータを遮断することで知る能力を強調して増えるんですね
それによって まああらゆるもの
何も知りたくはない もう何にもとらわれたくないという心の解放
自由っていうのは現れてくる
その人の 例えば悟った人の心には
もう何もそういう現象
なんとかもう入りません
そういうことですから
この本当の能力がある人っていうのは
ああいうことっていうのは絶対いくら理由があっても言うはずもないんです
財布の中にどれぐらいあるのかとかね
あの あの本に何が書いてあるのかとかね
まるっきりこれはもう絶対言うはずもない
だからこの世の中で秘密文書とか存在しなくなっちゃうでしょうに
誰かがその能力あると
いくら何でも見られたりすることできますからね
何の能力もない人だったら
政府の機密文書なんか盗もうとするかもしれませんだけど
そちらで目で見ているような見られる能力がある人っていうのは絶対それしないんです
何の意味もないんです
そういう道徳的な問題で
これは基本的なところで
そういうことをやらないんだからこそ
道徳を犯さないんだからこそ
体に対しても執着ないんだからこそ
ついてくる能力で だからその遮断する方程式によって心は解脱になるんです
ということで まああまりわかりやすい例でね
[ページをめくる音]